i'm watching doctors like you
who are doing what i consider to be the
fundamental job
in medicine which is to scientifically
evaluate phenomena whether that is a
patient who has a mysterious set of
symptoms or whether that's a pandemic
about which we are learning the nature
of the pathogen
doctors are supposed to be
scientists and that means that they
don't simply dispense wisdom from on
high what they do is they use often
informally a version of the scientific
method
to discover the nature of a phenomena a
phenomenon
and
then learn how to effectively treat it
and doctors like you have been learning
about covet as we all have
but those who have reached a conclusion
that is at odds with the public health
narrative
are i'm struggling to find an
alternative term but seem to be
gaslit
you're being told effectively that the
pathogen you're confronting
isn't what you think it is and i'm
wondering what that looks like from your
perspective
well what you describe is what's called
inferential thinking that we're always
drawing inferences from a series of
observations and with a new problem like
this there's a an unfolding new series
of observations that come out basically
almost every day now right or every week
and month that we learn new things so we
actually change our conclusions based on
what we've learned in many ways it's one
of the most exciting times in medical
science and i've witnessed to my entire
career the excitement is extraordinary
and the uh to tensions are great because
there's always tensions as we uh are
humbled
by uh finding out that maybe what we had
previously thought now uh has uh you
know is not supportable that we were on
the wrong track and now we need to
change science is ever changing and
you're right doctors uh who are treating
patients you know have to employ science
based on making inferences but they also
have to employ the art of medicine this
idea of having a medical hunch and
following it to its conclusion the best
we can therapeutically because people
are dying and that's the reason why we
could not wait for large randomized
trials which take two to five years and
then guidelines which take you know many
years after that the institute of
medicine says
from the time something is fully
understood and we have like a prevention
where therapy
applied it takes 17 years for full
implementation we obviously didn't have
that we didn't have 17 days to wait to
treat patients with covet 19. so i've
been involved as you implied very early
on with the early treatment response
that's gained a tremendous amount of
intention including you know basically
historic u.s senate testimony multiple
state senate testimony
treatment networks all over the united
states and then
in the last year turned my attention to
vaccine safety and efficacy because like
many doctors uh a
large number of americans
were volunteering for the first of its
kind vaccine program
and
um you know the response is is not
uncommon do you know the very first
doctor who put a polio patient on the
iron lung machine which actually saved
many lives in the polio pandemic he was
thrown off a staff i mean the history is
replete with this every doctor who had a
first innovation or had a first
observation on something that was a
breakthrough whether it be on the
efficacy side or the safety side
has been basically what you said gaslit
so what i say is if the gas lighting is
going on it means we're on the right
track
yeah flack over the target
[Music]